The Doctor is in... trouble.
The Stephen King adaptation Doctor Sleep,
which functions as a direct sequel to Stanley
Kubrick's classic The Shining, tanked at the
box office over the Veteran's Day weekend.
The only thing resembling a silver lining:
it wasn't alone.
The movie, which adapts King's 2013 novel
of the same name, arrived in theaters with
a sterling pedigree.
It was directed by Mike Flanagan, who was
at the helm of the excellent Gerald's Game,
a Netflix original which ported over another
of the master's works to the screen; King
himself gave Doctor Sleep a ringing endorsement,
and a great many horror fans consider The
Shining to be among the greatest fright flicks
of all time.
"Heeere's Johnny!"
All of these things considered, the story
of a now-adult Danny Torrance still coming
to terms with his unique powers - and the
harrowing events which took place during his
childhood stay at the Overlook Hotel - was
expected to clean up to the tune of $25 to
$30 million dollars domestic.
Shockingly, it came nowhere close to that
total, pulling in an absolutely anemic $14.1
million dollars at the stateside box office.
It was a disheartening development for studio
Warner Bros., as good reviews and word of
mouth weren't nearly enough to prop up Doctor
Sleep.
The movie was kept out of the weekend's top
spot by Roland Emmerich's historical drama
Midway, which has received mixed-to-negative
critical notices and claimed victory with
a $17.5 million haul, which itself is not
exactly impressive.
Considering that September's It: Chapter Two
underperformed pretty severely for the studio
compared with its 2017 predecessor, the failure
of Doctor Sleep could be indicative of a trend:
the beginning of the end of the King Renaissance,
which has seen such properties as The Mist,
Mr. Mercedes, Pet Sematary, and In the Tall
Grass successfully adapted for screens large
and small in just the last few years.
A slew of additional King adaptations are
currently in the works, including television
series based on The Stand and Lisey's Story,
and feature films based on Salem's Lot, The
Long Walk, and From a Buick 8.
It should be said that Doctor Sleep might
have had a bit more success if moviegoers
hadn't inexplicably decided to stay away from
the theater altogether over the weekend.
A little quick math reveals that the top two
movies of Veterans' Day weekend 2019 only
managed about a $32 million dollar domestic
haul, and when we compare and contrast with
the same weekend in recent years, the difference
is downright eye-popping.
Consider that during the same frame in 2018,
Universal and Illumination's animated feature
The Grinch topped the box office with a whopping
$67.6 million gross, more than twice the total
that Doctor Sleep and Midway combined for.
The Freddie Mercury biopic Bohemian Rhapsody
came in second during that frame with $31.2
million, a respectable total that this year's
top two just barely managed to eclipse.
In 2017, the top spot went to Thor: Ragnarok
with a $57.1 million haul, and the second
and third spots were filled by Daddy's Home
2 with $29.7 million, and Murder on the Orient
Express with $28.7 million.
It's plain to see that in each of the last
two years, audiences were all about heading
out to the multiplex over the Veteran's Day
weekend, and that this year, that trend hit
a brick wall.
As noted by The Hollywood Reporter, even Paul
Dergarabedian of Comscore - an analytics company
which provides marketing data to media and
advertising firms-— remarked that this past
weekend, quote, "was like some weird alternative
box-office universe."
Unfortunately, it was one in which Doctor
Sleep, by most accounts a very good film and
a very worthy sequel to The Shining, found
itself stuck.
Hopefully, the flick's jaw-droppingly weak
performance will turn out to be a fluke, as
year-to-date box office revenue is trailing
significantly behind last year despite the
stunning success of flicks like Joker - which
is now the most profitable comic book movie
ever - and Avengers: Endgame, which is simply
the highest-grossing film in history.
With such potential smashes as Frozen II and
Star Wars Episode IX: The Rise of Skywalker
still to come, it's certainly not too late
for 2019 to turn it around - but as far as
Doctor Sleep goes, we're calling the time,
because the patient has no pulse.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.